>> Greg: MOMENTS AFTER
GETTING ENDORSED FOR DEMOCRATS
FILLING THE SLOW ROLLING
DISASTER, JOE BIDEN QUICKLY
INSPIRE CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
DECISION.
>> WE HOLD THESE TRUTHS TO BE
SELF EVIDENT THAT ALL MEN
CREATED BY -- YOU KNOW THE
THING.
LOOK, TOMORROW SUPER THURSDAY
STARTED.
SERIOUSLY COME I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL.
I TELL YOU WHAT, I’M RUSHING
AHEAD, ARE NOT A QUESTION MARK
>> Greg: AS ALWAYS, BLAME IT
ON THE RUSSIAN.
I WONDER IF TRUMP NOTICED.
>> TOMORROW, VOTERS IN STATES
ACROSS THE NATION WILL HEAD TO
THE POLLS FOR SUPER TUESDAY, NOT
SUPER THURSDAY.
[LAUGHTER]
HE SAID SUPER THURSDAY.
YOU CAN’T DO THESE THINGS.
HE IS CONSTANTLY NAMING THE
WRONG STATE.
IT IS GREAT TO BE IN THE STATE
OF OHIO, NO, NO, NO I’M SORRY
YOU ARE IN NORTH CAROLINA.
I HONESTLY DON’T THINK HE KNOWS
WHAT OFFICE HE IS RUNNING FOR A
PAIR THEY WILL PUT HIM IN A HOME
IN OTHER PEOPLE WILL BE RUNNING
THE COUNTRY.
AND THEY WILL BE SUPER LEFT
RADICAL CRAZIES.
>> Greg: EVERYBODY MAKE GASP
BUT FASTER THAN RABBITS AND
WHILE SOMETIMES TRUMP’S WORDS
ARE SHOCKING, THEY DON’T HINT AT
AN UNDERLYING DECLINE.
BITE AND REMIND YOU HE’S NOT
GETTING ANY YOUNGER, LET ALONE
WISER AND IT MAKES YOU WONDER WH
ENDORSEMENTS FROM AMY,
PETE AND BETO REALLY MEAN.
IS JOE LEADING A PARADE OF
ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT, OR IS THIS
A GARNEY RACE TO PUSH JOE ACROSS
THE FINISH LINE ON A STRETCHER?
HE FACES A BIGGER CHALLENGE
THOUGH.
HE IS A MODERATE BY TODAY’S
LOONY LEFT STANDARDS, BUT HIS
ONE AND ONLY IDEA IS GET RID OF
THAT ORANGE MIMI.
THAT IS NOT A VISION, THAT IS A
COMPLAINT.
MEANWHILE BERNIE IS STRONG
DESPITE BEING WRONG AND WHY HE
ATTRACTS THE YOUTH, THE MAD AND
THE CRAZY.
IN A WORLD WHERE WE IDEALIZE THE
BOWL, THE RADICAL IS THAN A
BUNDLING MODERATE, EVEN WITH
EAR HAIR.
IT IS NOT FAIR, IT IS NOT SMART
BUT THROWING ALL THEIR WEIGHT
BEHIND THE FANTASY OF
IMPEACHMENT AND DIDN’T SEE THIS
COMING?
INSTEAD THE DEMS STUCK WITH
THREE VOTING CHOICES, TWO CRANKY
OLD MAN AND SLEEPING IN.
I PUT MY MONEY ON THE SNOOZE
BUTTON.
>> DANA, DANA, DANA, WHAT DID WE
LEARN FROM 2016 RICK PERRY?
NEVER START SOMETHING YOU CAN’T
FINISH.
REMEMBER I GOT THREE THINGS.
NEVER START A REALLY FAMOUS
QUOTE.
>> Dana: IF YOU CAN’T MAIL THE
>> Greg: IF YOU CAN’T NAIL THE
QUOTE, GET OFF OFF THE VOTE.
>> Dana: TREY GOWDY ON
SATURDAY NIGHT SAID SOMETIMES
IT’S WATCHING A CHAIN SMOKER
PHILIP’S GAS TANK, WAITING FOR
THE LIKE THE DISASTER.
[LAUGHTER]
I THINK, LOOK, IT IS CONCERNING
AND THIS CAMPAIGN, WELL MET, IF
WE ARE REALLY GOING TO BE THE
FRONT RUNNER, CAN HE HANDLE IT?
THAT IS A LOT OF ENERGY.
NOW, WINNING SOMETIMES GIVE YOU
A PEP IN YOUR STEP.
BUT THE OTHER THING ABOUT
JOE BIDEN, IT IS LIKE PEOPLE
THINK HE IS CHARMING.
I GET IT, HE MET TUESDAY.
THEY ARE SUPER FORGIVING.
>> Greg: I THINK SO TOO
BECAUSE WE ALWAYS HAVE SOMEONE
IN OUR LIVES, JESSE.
EVERY DAY YOU SAY SOMETHING THAT
I GO --
>> Jesse: THANK YOU, GREG.
THAT WAS ME YESTERDAY.
I WAS LISTENING TO RUSH LIMBAUGH
AND JOE PULLED THE PLUG BECAUSE
HE DIDN’T WANT TO SAY UNDER GOD
IN FRONT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
AUDIENCE.
HE SAID THAT WAS THE SMARTEST
THING JOE BIDEN SAID IN A VERY
LONG TIME.
LISTEN, BERNIE SANDERS IS A
MESS.
I DON’T EVEN THINK BERNIE KNOWS
IF HE CAN RUN THE COUNTRY.
BERNIE IS LIKE A HECKLER AT A
GAME THAT JUST YELLS OUT OBAMA.
YOU DON’T MAKE THE HECKLER OF
THE MANAGER.
YOU JUST GIVE THE GUY POPCORN
AND PAT HIM ON THE HEAD.
THIS GUY KNOWS HE CAN’T WIN AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS -- YOU CAN’T
BLAME THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FOR
RIGGING IT AGAINST HIM.
IF I WAS A DEMOCRAT TO COME I
WOULD RIG THE HECK OUT OF THIS
THING.
AND DON’T GO ANYWHERE NEAR THE
WHITE HOUSE.
MEANWHILE, JOE BIDEN IS LEFT
WITH CRAZY BERNIE.
AND HE CAN’T EVEN SURVIVE A GOOD
NEWS CYCLE WITHOUT WRAPPING UP
GAS.
WHAT NUMBERS ARE COMING OUT OF
HIS MOUTH OR WHO HE’S TALKING
TO.
IT IS A LACKLUSTER CANADA WITH A
BAD CAMPAIGN.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN JOE BIDEN
BUMPER STICKER, HAVE ANY OF YOU?
I’VE NEVER SEEN A JOE BIDEN
CROWD.
HE CAN’T GET THROUGH AN
INTERVIEW.
THE GUY IS SLOW AND HE IS
SLOWING DOWN.
IT’S NOT A GOOD LOOK FOR JOEL,
BUT, THE GOOD NEWS IS, WE GET TO
WATCH THE WHOLE THING UNFOLD.
AND IT IS A BEAUTIFUL THING.
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK AMY,
PETE AND BETO WERE PROMISED
ANYTHING?
COULD THIS BE A QUID PRO QUO?
>> Juan: I THINK YOU SHOULD
STAY AWAY FROM QUID PRO QUO AND
WE HEARD A LOT ABOUT THAT FROM
TRUMP IN UKRAINE.
BUT I THINK AMY KLOBUCHAR,
AMY KLOBUCHAR SAID THAT SHE WAS
PROMISED AND WANTED TO DO WHAT
SHE FELT WAS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO IN ORDER TO UNIFY THE PARTYAN
DONALD TRUMP.
I WILL SAY THIS, I’M STRUCK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND CLEARLY,
YOUR DELIGHT IN THE GAS,
INDICATE AGAIN THE REPUBLICANS
ARE MOST WORRIED ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
I DON’T WANT TO RUN AGAINST HIM.
THAT IS WHY THE PRESIDENT SENT
RUDY TO THE UKRAINE TO DIG UP
DIRT ON COWS WHO, JOE BIDEN.
AND I HAVE THE FEELING, HUNTER
BIDEN’S NAME WILL BUBBLE UP IN A
SECOND.
AND IN CONGRESS, THEY ARE
PLANNING MORE HEARINGS.
I THINK THAT WHAT THE RIGHT-WING
IS INTENT ON, THEY LIKE TO MOCK
JOE BIDEN.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU AGAIN,
DEMOCRATS AND I WILL USE DANA’S
WORD, THINK IT IS CHARMING THAT
HE IS AUTHENTIC, RIGHT, THAT IS
SOMETHING YOU VALUE GREATLY,
JESSE, SOMEONE REAL.
SOMEONE YOU CAN TOUCH AND NO.
>> Jesse: AND HE CAN TOUCH
YOU.
>> Juan: IT IS ALSO THE CASE
AND I THINK CLEARLY THAT IT’S
NOT JUST MY OPINION BECAUSE WHAT
DO WE SEE IN THE POLLS,
ESPECIALLY POLLS IN
SOUTH CAROLINA?
IMMIGRANTS DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
STUFF.
IT IS REPUBLICANS WHO CARE ABOUT
IT BECAUSE THE BOWLING, THE
MOCKING, THE PARADING.
>> Greg: NO DEMOCRATS ARE
PUTTING THIS OUT, KATIE.
>> Katie: JOE BIDEN’S APPEAL
AT THIS POINT HE’S A STATESMAN,
THE GUY IN WASHINGTON FOR A
DECADE SO WE KNOWS WHAT HE’S
DOING AND WE CAN TRUST HIM TO BE
SOMEONE WHO IS RELIABLE TO BE A
COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
AND SOMEONE WHO CONTINUALLY
LOOKS INCOMPETENT WITH BASIC
THINGS WHEN IT COMES TO A
ONE-ON-ONE MATCH UP WITH
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO HAVE A
HARD TIME TO MAKE A CASE TO
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
WHO ARE LIKING THE ECONOMY, WHO
THINKS PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
A DECENT JOB.
WHO IS A COMPETENT COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
JOE BIDEN WILL HAVE A VERY HARD
TIME DOING THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO BERNIE SANDERS,
I THINK HE IS A THREAT AS WELL.
I DON’T THINK YOU CAN
UNDERESTIMATE WHERE HE WILL GO.
HE WORKED TO WIN THE NOMINATION
WHICH IS LOOKING MORE LIKE THE
CONVENTION GOING INTO TONIGHT.
BUT THE COALITION HE HAD IN
NEVADA IS ONE THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE LOOKING AT LATINOS, YOUNG
WOMEN, YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND THE WHOLE DEMOCRATIC
ESTABLISHMENT WOULD GET BEHIND
HIM, HE CERTAINLY WOULD BE MORE
OF THE MACHINE THEN HE IS RIGHT
NOW.
SO I WOULD NOT UNDERESTIMATE HIS